on soit faire rêver merci d'être avec
nous vous avez présenté à l'assemblée le
20 avril une proposition de loi pour un
service public du médicament
que vous inspirent les derniers
développements la réaction de sanofi
devoir favoriser les états unis c'est
évidemment scandaleux parce qu'on voit
bien que on est au coeur de la
marchandisation de la santé et la
politique de sanofi correspond à cela
c'est à dire que l'on cherche finalement
toujours à faire du profit et a dealé
avec les uns avec les autres
je crois que franchement ça n'est pas
sérieux de manière générale y compris là
on voit bien ça ça nous apparaît de
manière encore plus évidente de 7,6 à un
backside faire profiter à toutes et à
tous il s'agit pas simplement de donner
aux plus offrants
alors c'est ce qu'a dit en tout cas
c'est ce qu'a affirmé le patron français
voulait rassurer dire voilà ça sera
accessible à tous
mais est ce que finalement c'est
possible de rendre avec sa accessible à
tous tout simplement s n'est ce pas un
voeu pieux
je crois que c'est tout à fait possible
ça d'ailleurs
existait il ya des vaccins qui sont tout
à fait disponible qui que chacun peut
maintenant produire et donc voilà je
crois que c'est tout à fait nécessaire
pour le vaccin du coc u19 qui pour
l'instant n'existe hélas pas encore mais
qui est en cours de recherche où
j'espère qu'il qu'il adviendra un jour
le problème c'est que si vous voulez les
déclarations parce qu'elle a eu une
précédente de la part de la direction de
sanofi j'aime quand même le trouble il a
beau avoir un peu rétro pédaler depuis
aujourd'hui on se dit quand même qu'il
ya une discussion engagée dans
lesquelles sanofi et essaye de placer
ses pions et de toujours avec cette même
quête finalement de profiter or là nous
avons je crois quand même un besoin
essentiel qui nous est commun à toute
l'humanité
haas auquel on peut pas faire ce type de
calcul ça n'est pas sérieux ce n'est pas
possible il faut que lui fois que le
vaccin sera découverte je ne sais pas
par qui tu puisses sa composition sa
formule c'est sa fabrication puisse
attendre du public afin que un peu
partout on puisse le fabriqué dans de
bonnes conditions je crois que l'om est
le meilleur garant de tous avait alors
ce que dit sanofi c'est que tout
simplement on a besoin de partage
les risques pour produire les doses
nécessaires et qu en clair les états
unis apportent beaucoup plus de soutien
financier que l'europe donc en gros
c'est à eux d'en profiter en premier ça
vous met en colère ce genre de
raisonnement extrêmement réaliste voire
cynique
oui bien sûr c'est une forme d'égoïsme
qui aimait profondément révoltant et
inacceptable compris de la part du jeu
demandeurs sont les états unis moi je ne
demande pas à ce qu'ils aient la
priorité à la france voit que le sujet
n'est pas là nous avons dans notre
capacité de production de médicaments je
trouve ça que j'ai proposé ça te cette
loi qui n'a pas été encore débattue mais
cela étant dit la france a payé beaucoup
hein
nous avons donné l'année dernière je
prends de 110 et 130 millions d'euros à
sanofi de crédit impôt recherche sanofi
les médicaments de sanofi sont
remboursés par la sécurité sociale pour
une large part quand même hein donc
voilà je crois qu'il faut et puis sanofi
à verser des dividendes aux actionnaires
je crois que c'était 4 milliards d'euros
d'année l'année dernière je suis bien
c'est considérable faut pas nous
raconter des histoires c'est pas comme
ça que les choses doivent fonctionner
mais je pense qu'il est temps maintenant
de remettre de l'ordre dans la
production du médicament je m de la
démocratie là dedans et de remettre de
la transparence
emmanuel macron réagi aujourd'hui il
souhaite extraire le vaccin du bien
public mondial il va d'ailleurs
rencontré la direction sanofi
prochainement qu'est ce que vous
attendez
concrètement du président de la
république dans cette affaire je crois
qu'il faut taper du poing sur la table
il faut exiger effectivement que le
vaccin qui se sera découvert qu'ils
puissent être un bien commun et moi je
pense que sanofi avant la crise avaient
déjà commencé à délocaliser non
seulement de la production maintenance
des médicaments que nous produisions ici
mais le centre aujourd'hui et à
délocaliser aussi à recherche
je crois qu'il faut taper du poing sur
la table on a parlé beaucoup de
relocaliser un certain nombre de
productions celle du médicament a fait
partie et je crois que il faut que nous
donnions un outil c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait cette proposition de loi que nous
aurions un outil donc il faudra le dire
à sanofi préfère m'en de production
publique de médicaments
je crois qu'il ya là matière maintenant
ça paraît comme une évidence pas
simplement laisser le marché sanofi
rang de l'élite pharma décider de
l'avenir de notre société
clairement cette crise pour vous pierre
dharréville a réveillé a révélé des
failles dans le marché du médicament en
france
oui d'abord il y avait dès le début des
pénuries qui se sont qui se sont révélés
qui ont exposé un d'année en année
depuis miami 200 médicaments d'intérêt
majeurs sont trouvés en tension où une
pénurie l'année dernière fois que
c'était huit cents l'année précédente
seulement pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée donc on a véritablement un souci
sur la l'organisation la production de
médicaments se faire plus tendu qui se
délocalise au on peut pas vouloir gérer
comme ça ils médicaments simplement pour
optimiser les profits ça n'est pas
possible ça n'est pas sérieux et je
crois que c'est pour cela qu'il faut les
remettre de la démocratie là dedans
remettent aussi d'intervention publique
donc pas simplement laisser quelques
actionnaires décider notre stratégie en
matière de sentiers et de médicaments
est-ce qu'ils sont clairement aussi que
l'état reprenne la main sur les
laboratoires oui a eu d'une certaine
façon il faut il faut reprendre la main
et les choses il ya déjà on lave et rien
pour un certain nombre de laboratoires
qui se trouvaient en difficulté je pense
à ça marche du côté de lyon qui
produisait tous médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur et qui était en
liquidation judiciaire qui aurait dû je
pense fort prix pour pouvoir continuer
cette production là je pense qu'à chaque
fois que nécessaire d'être fois pas se
priver de faire grossir un outil de
production public qui soit suffisamment
forte pour répondre à nos besoins en cas
de crise mais qui pèse aussi sur le
marché du médicament qui le rendent plus
vertueux qui oblige les big pharmas et
bien se comporter autrement parce que
s'ils ne le font pas et bien il y aura
une petite production pudique sur la
place qui sera l'europe et merci pierre
d'arrivée d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france